the most important thing that would we
deliver at the for season it's really
happiness it's an experience that people
can come back to people have been coming
back to the Four Seasons restaurant for
over 50 years the only president that
has never been here was actually Richard
Nixon I really do not understand why but
I mean the first president came to the
Four Seasons restaurant was John F
Kennedy and ever since then every person
has to come to true season multiple
times
the restaurants famed Grill Room serves
dishes priced up to $75 a plate to
Manhattan's elite
but come July 16th the home of the New
York City Power Lunch will be shuttered
I think most of New York City people are
doesn't really not happy about the fact
that the lease was not renewed and a lot
of them are very upset about it but
there is nothing we can do we have to
move forward it's just two months left
for farewells at the Four Seasons and
for a special goodbye patrons can pay
$250 a head for a glimpse behind the
magic on Saturdays The Four Seasons is
hosting cooking classes over three hours
guests learn to shuck oysters make
sauces for the crisp farmhouse Deb
and prepare panna cotta all while
drinking lots of wine I think it's
really wonderful for anybody to be able
to go in the back of a kitchen
especially liked for seasoned
restaurants
following the lessons guests enjoy the
spoils of their labor this is actually a
three litres of champagne you know so
it's a double Magnum oh my champagne is
gonna go all the way up four seasons
hopes this experience will push patrons
to their next unknown location the
party's not over yet it's only the
beginning